[Music]
welcome to best life 30 your 30-day
journey to creating the best
life possible for yourself you can watch
just this video or if you want to sign
up for the whole series for free
and get the bonus companion worksheets
that go along with this video
check out the link in the description
below alright so today is bonus aim
number four and we're going to learn how
to optimize our exercise
[Music]
once i wake up i use waking up as the
very trigger that reminds me to work out
i'm not
i work out every day but i'm not one of
those guys that really loves working out
but working out is so powerful in fact
it's one of the
most powerful things that you can do for
yourself i'll put it second
only to reading so i get up first thing
as soon as i roll out of bed i go
straight to the gym and i start working
out now the reason working out is so
powerful
there's tons of research uh you can
start with the book spark
by john ratey who's actually been on the
show incredibly powerful book that draws
parallels between
exercise and cognitive performance and
how it can have
massive impacts and just some really
really powerful stories in that book
so can't encourage enough for you to
read that another iq guest norman
deutsch
has talked a lot about the brain and how
it heals itself in fact in his book
called the way the brain heals
talking about how walking specifically
and exercise in general can have a
tremendous impact
on the brain's ability to rewire itself
so not only is there just neurological
science behind why getting exercise is
so powerful but beyond that moving into
some softer science
i will tell you that developing
discipline is one of the most critical
things that you need to be successful
being successful comes with a litany of
things
that you're not going to want to do but
you're going to have to do them anyway
you're going to have to push yourself
when you don't want you can have to get
out of bed when you'd rather lay in bed
you're going to have to work on that
saturday when your friends are out
partying and you'd rather
be partying but there's that awesome
quote don't sell out what you want most
for what you want right now and
discipline is going to be the thing that
allows you to do that but you need
an area in which you can train that
discipline nothing comes without
training not discipline
uh nothing not even a great relationship
even a great relationship a relationship
based on love and chemistry and all
these amazing things
i still think needs training to get
great and having to show up every day at
the gym
develops that discipline having to lift
long past the point of fatigue having to
push yourself long past the point of
pain
having to get disciplined about your
diet to make sure that you see results
from the exercise all of it is feeding
into
strengthening your discipline and having
those little wins of whoa
i couldn't curl this weight yesterday
but i can curl it today that kind of
thing
really helps to build your confidence
and as i'm sure you guys have heard
before and i'm sure as you
feel in your gut when you've got
confidence you hold yourself differently
you think about yourself differently you
act differently
and that confidence is born of those
little wins and if you can put yourself
in situations where you can have these
small
incremental victories every day and
you're pushing yourself and you're
seeing the results not only of getting a
victory but you're seeing the physical
changes that your body goes through
it's going to re-conceptualize your
internal narrative
and that internal narrative is
everything and simply going to the gym
every day
you get to change the story you tell
yourself if you have anxiety
if you have post-traumatic stress
disorder if you have any kind of mental
health condition
it's nothing to be ashamed of and it's
nothing to hide and it's something to
hit head-on with
there's one thing one thing that if you
did every single day
no joke it would make an extraordinary
difference
in whatever mental health issue you're
struggling with and that is exercise
and the reason why i say this is not
based on my own personal experience
it's based on the fact that the um
i think it's the american psychiatric
association this is coming from dr john
ratey a friend of mine who has written a
ton of books
about not only adhd but also the
benefits of exercise and what it has on
your brain
but he's also a professor at harvard and
a practicing
clinician and this is his area of
expertise
and one of the things that they now
mandate as a diagnosis for anybody with
depression or anxiety
or any mental illness frankly is you've
got to exercise every day
and the reason you've got to exercise
every day is because what we know about
human beings is that when you physically
move
your physiology changes and that changes
your brain
getting your heart rate up getting
outside breathing
feeling connected getting out of your
house which may make you feel depressed
and trapped
doing that every day that physical push
you don't have to run
you don't have to go to an aerobics
class get outside with your dog in the
woods
walk with a good friend for two or three
miles doing that every single day
not only moves your body which changes
your mind it gets you out of your
physical environment which is one of the
things that people with depression tend
to have a hard time doing
and it also creates a bit of momentum
and a bit of a routine in your life
you take on just that single thing
get outside and exercise every single
day as if your life depends upon it
because you know what
it does your brain needs it your body
needs it
your mental health needs it i used to be
able to
eat whatever i want and then in six
weeks i could get in any shape
i wanted to get into but that's not the
case
anymore we're we're around the 12 or 14
week
uh uh mandatory uh training to
to do anything but but i love it i enjoy
um i enjoy the discipline of it for me
working on on your body is the beginning
of everything you know your mind starts
to work better
you're a better husband a better father
a better friend and
life is just better when you
you know care for your body at the
highest level my whole focus is how do
you get the greatest result with the
least amount of time or energy
intensity trumps duration all day long
we're gonna do
the briefest workout that'll max you out
all right
let's do it next thing i'm going to do
is have my trainer here his name is
billy
we're going to do this one first let's
pop you over here
[Music]
it's designed to make every muscle in
your body get the maximum demand in the
shortest time with the least trauma
we're gonna do basically a chest press
on here your job
is you're gonna push as hard as you can
continuously and a time roll going on
you're gonna
hold and keep pushing as hard as you can
until the timer's done it goes for five
seconds go for it full tilt
that's it go go go go go go go good good
good harder harder harder
come on baby come on come on come on
come on come on come on come on come on
come on okay let go
good now we're going to leg press full
tilt as hard as you can
go go go go go go go go go go go look at
this monster
look at this go let it go oh there you
go nice job you're done
okay there's gonna be core pull go go go
go go
go go go go done that one not quite as
good you know you've done what 15
seconds of exercise so far total right
yeah i felt like i did like an hour's
workout if you want we'll put you on the
little torture machine this this is
something we only do once or twice a
week you don't do this every day
it is going to push you aerobically and
anaerobically there will be a point
where it's pure anaerobic and so that's
where you're going to need your will
right to be able to do it and so we're
filming you so you can't stop
okay pop on here go full filter now
start it up
go full tilt all the way and push push
as hard as you can that's it
come on baby come on come on push push
oh you're going push push push push push
you got it you got it you got it got it
oh don't let it go
keep going man don't put it get one
minute down three minutes to go you
should feel like you're about to die but
you're not
last minute everything you got for a
minute you can do anything for a minute
this is where you get all the growth
getting back above 60. you can do it
you're a beast come on beast got this is
this 12 seconds line up two
seconds second one go go go go
go come on again again
finish strong
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you're gonna feel it for the next couple
of days brother so all we're gonna do is
cleanse your body a little bit more
you're gonna put your heat and then put
you in the cold and you're done
[Music]
so what you're gonna do is you're gonna
pop in here
for as long as you can take it put
yourself to the edge which
for most people is about four to five
minutes and then when you're done
without delay once you're there you're
gonna drop right down into the cold
punch here
all ready come on in say goodbye to him
one last time
good knowing you [ __ ]
[Music]
put some water on there
[Music]
how are you feeling by the way it's
pretty extreme
well that's what i do all the time so
you get a better feel on the four-minute
machine
two minutes in i i didn't think i was
actually going to be able to do it
the voice in my head kept saying just
just give up it's fine just give up it's
fine
but thank god we had a camera screaming
at you
yeah exactly
there's a lot of people that are eating
food and then by the end of the day your
body's in a crisis yeah
nobody's just processing all this
[ __ ] yeah and people ask me that too
they go
you know how much do you sleep first of
all i get asked all the time so i go to
bed around 11 i woke up wake up around 4
30 every day so that's five and a half
hours
sometimes i sleep more than that
sometimes i go to bed at 10 10 30 11
sometimes i stay up later
but when the person says to me oh you
know i can't do that i feel horrible how
can i feel better and my first question
is like what are you eating
what are you eating because if you're
eating cheetos and chocolate chip
cookies for lunch there's no way you're
going to feel good i don't care if you
slept 12 hours the night before
yeah that's a it's a giant factor and if
you're eating a big
like [ __ ] lunch filled with nonsense
like your body's got to process all that
stuff and so the end of the day yeah
you're going to lose your willpower
so like when five o'clock six o'clock
rolls around you're gonna be tired
but if you have a healthy lunch and you
know you're
you're properly fueled and then you also
have positive people in your life
everyone's motivated by the end of the
day you're going to feel good like say
if you're go
if you're doing jiu jitsu with a bunch
of other people that are doing jiu jitsu
everybody's enjoying it you're looking
forward to that 6 30 class
everybody's fired up you get out of work
you're pumped man you
what you doing when you get out of work
you're fueling up with water you're
trying to get some electrolytes in you
because you know you're going to get out
there on the mat so you're going to
sweat it out
yeah and the thing you got to do too is
when you get done with work and it was a
grind and you didn't get you
ate crappy food and whatever happened
happened and you got yelled at by your
boss or whatever
and the real easy decision is to be like
i'm not gonna go train tonight
those are the nights you gotta train
because that is gonna kick you back on
the track real quick when you get in
there and you see your boys and they're
they're getting ready to
tear you up on the mats and that's going
to get you on track as opposed to going
home and watching tv which isn't going
to do anything for you
yeah and if it's just not your thing
whatever the [ __ ] your thing is just go
and do it just force yourself to do it
and if you feel like
because you ate lunch then your lunch
was you know filled with bullsh
well then hey dummy don't eat lunch
tomorrow tomorrow try a nice salad
yeah try a salad with some salmon and
see how you feel then you're like hey i
feel way better today at six o'clock
duh yeah now your decision-making will
be better like people don't understand
how significant it is like all these
little decisions they those are like
that's the path for the rest of your
existence on earth and if you decide to
go to
cheetos chocolate chip cookie route
you're you're just making a sh
path you're carving your path through
broken rocks and
glass and it's not the way to go there's
no doubt that the the life change
decision isn't one big decision that you
make it's all these little tiny
decisions it's
you know having a salad instead of
cheetos that's that's that's what it is
on a daily basis
and if you think about that and then you
just make the right decision on those
little things
that's where that's where the change is
when i take a spin class a really good
spin class where i'm loving the music
and i can
absolutely let go and charge into
my body i can like feel into every
single movement i can let the sweat
pour off of me i can get lost in the in
the rhythm
i find that it opens up a channel in me
like nothing else
sometimes it could be taking a great
walk i think i want to push you a little
bit on your opponent's channel so i
really understand it
yes is it where you feel like you can
hear the little voice in your mind is it
where you're
ironically you can't try and force it to
show up
so often times when i hit a roadblock in
my business and i'm just at this
stalemate i'm like oh i can go this way
or this way
i'm stuck let me go work out let me go
take a walk let me take a spin class let
me take a dance class
and get immersed in that so that my
subconscious and the rest of my body has
a chance to
work through it and it will produce an
answer or an insight when i'm not
looking for it it could happen at the
end of the class
when i'm done in the shower sometimes it
happens on the bike it doesn't matter
but what you just have to do is have a
level of faith and trust
and you can't go in forcing it i feel
like
what happens through exercise and again
it's when you have
that level of faith to surrender to your
body to surrender that
you have wisdom within you that you're
not going to access grinding to it
it unfurls almost like a flower blooms
when it's ready
if you're see self improvements not even
just with cars with your own body you
know when you go work out
do you feel better when you come out of
a gym all pumped up or you feel better
when you haven't worked out for a month
of course you know you're when you go to
the gym you know you're building your
you know something happens when you see
changes in your body with your assets
when you see even gaining a good friend
i have my down days you know
i'm sure you do too are all human you
know you could have all the money in the
world you're still going to have a bad
day
you know absolutely you don't know
what's going to cause it but you know
you do and
you know for me working out is great i
have a personal trainer three times a
week
and then when i don't have my personal
trainer i just get out of bed and
drop on the floor and do 20 push-ups 30
push-ups i do it until i can't do it
anymore
and then i hit the shower and i feel
great you know
and it's you know it's just keeping
the fluids going you know your mind
fresh yeah because workout not just
improves your physics it also helps your
mind agreed
and sometimes it helps your mentality
more than your physique but people don't
realize that you know
it helps you focus when you come to work
and you haven't
exercised you're lethargic sometimes it
takes an
hour or two before you even get into the
flow of doing things right
when you exercise prior to coming to
work your mind is sharper right off the
bat you just kind of want to get into it
you're in the flow of things
you're going you're moving you're coming
up with better ideas better ways of
you know having this thing advance to
the next level what if we do this what
if we do that what if we do this
everything does better because your mind
is sharper if you don't have energy
you can't solve problems why because so
think about it this way if you're in a
room in a board room everybody's going
back and forth trying to solve problems
and you see everybody do this one signal
let me tell you what the signal is this
is the signal you ready
this is the signal of somebody saying we
should just figure something out and
leave the boardroom this is how it looks
like
you know what the signal is what is the
signal i want to go home
right the signals i want to finish this
meeting here we should already wrap up
you could have been seven minutes away
from solving this problem in a way
so effective that would have helped you
take your business to the next level
but you were so tired because you're
lethargic from not exercising
not having proper diet that you just
made the good decision instead of the
best decision
so you don't advance to the next level
and by the way this happens in sports
this happens in business this happens in
everything you watch because you can
tell
when decisions are made and this is what
happens the person goes like this
ah let's just do it that's not the best
decisions that's just a decision
it's not the best decision the best
decision is um
if we do this it does this if we do this
it does this if we do this it does this
here let's write the sun
you know what i think this is the best
decision we're moving with this what do
you guys think great
let's talk about running all right first
big picture this is what matters
and the body is just there to like keep
this thing
running the brain big picture
[Music]
this is the west side highway this is
where i run almost every day
uh it's lovely here river on that side
city on that side
this is the one mile check-in and i feel
great
i have not always been a runner i ran
cross-country
in middle school when i was like 11. i
didn't really start running until i was
26
27 28 28.
what year is it
[Music]
all right still on the west side highway
now i'm in midtown so i'm halfway up the
island from where i was before
this is mile number six and i feel great
i didn't start running till i was 28
because when i was 26
i was told i'd never be able to run
again here's what happened
i'm going to do this
okay so i borrowed candace's scooter
and i was driving down the street and
this dude ran a red light
and straight up just cremated the
scooter
and my leg i was in the hospital for
about a week
i was in surgery for like 12 hours this
is my
busted up leg as soon as i got to the
hospital they had to drill through my
leg with a drill to quickly put pressure
on it put it in traction
to slow the bleeding so when i was in
the hospital
right before they were going to release
me i asked the doctor how long until i'm
100
how long until i run and i'll never
forget
he said to me you'll be able to chase
after your kids
and you'll be able to chase after a taxi
cab down the street but you'll never be
able to run
again i cannot tell you
how much that freaked me out i was 26
years old
and being told that i would never run
again it was
devastating absolutely devastating
okay that's still the west side highway
on the other end of this tunnel
now i'm uptown i'm coming into the
island here
this is the eight-mile check-in and i
feel great
okay i found the footage all right so
this is
two years after i go to the hospital
this was
well here
those are my feet this is gross
you get the point so my first marathon
was an
unmitigated disaster i really like got
beat up
i sat down i was walking my time was
abhorrent
i hate doing something and not being
great at it
[Music]
okay this is the upper west side that's
central park
i just ran across the upper west side
i'm now entering
central park mile nine check in i feel
great
four months later i ran my second
marathon and
i really got i really got it together
okay this is the southernmost point in
central park that's 59th street
this is check-in number like 10 and
change and i feel great
somewhere i decided that running wasn't
enough and i started to really get into
triathlons
here's my favorite picture of myself
running a triathlon
just look at that intensity
[Music]
this is the easternmost side of
central park that's fifth avenue there
mile
12 and i feel great since being told by
that doctor that i'd never be able to
run again
i've run 22 marathons i've competed in
four ironman triathlons
probably a hundred other triathlons and
other road races
uh and i never looked back and we talked
about it last season season one
of the greatest vlog in history of the
world about how i work out so hard in
the mornings
two reasons one is that the hardest part
of my day
is now over it's 7 30 a.m and everything
i have to do
from now on will not be a
13 speed sprint on a 12 incline
followed by a decline bench and you
don't have to do that again all day
today which is great
and it's really important to start every
day making a mind
body connection and i know that sounds
like [ __ ] i know that sounds super
cliche
and it actually makes me throw up a
little bit to say it but it's super
true i'm more connected right now in my
pure exhaustion
than i will be at all during the rest of
the day
for sure had i not worked out
and now i'm going to think faster think
quicker be more decisive and be more
radical during my entire day to be more
productive
and be more successful i always try to
outwork people right that's just how
i made my mark so the game was at seven
i was like you know what i'm gonna come
to the staples center because we're
playing this one
lakers had kobe in shock okay this is
this is like the championship lakers
so you know i'm gonna get there at 3
o'clock i want to make sure i make 400
made shots
before i go back into the room and then
i sit in the zone and i get ready for
the game
who do i see i see kobe bryant already
working out
so once i set my foot across that line i
started working out and
so i worked out for a good hour hour and
a half and when i came off
after i was done i sat down and of
course i still heard the ball bouncing
i look down like this guy's this guy
still working out
he was working out like it looks like he
was in a dead sweat when i got here
and he's still going and it's not like
his moves are nonchalant
lazy he's doing like game moves you know
um i sit there and i
unleash my shoes i'm like i want to see
how long this goes let's get out there
and watch
another 25 minutes and they got done he
said okay
i think i've seen enough go play you
know come back
get in the sauna get ready for the game
that game he drops 40 on us okay
and after the game is over i'm like i
have to ask this guy i have to
understand
like why why he works like that
right so after games i'm like hey cove
like why
why were you in the gym for so long he's
like because i saw you come in
and i wanted you to know that it doesn't
matter how hard you work
that i'm willing to work harder than you
wow you just
you inspired me to be better right and
it was the first time i started to see
this level of competitiveness
where i said i need to start doing more
right wow
but you you never get better if you're
not willing to put in the time
and basketball is very similar to the
game of life there's going to be ups and
downs
it's not always going to be easy there
are going to be challenges
there's still going to be curveballs
thrown at me but if you put into work
and you constantly put in the work
that's the only way you're going to grow
we went out to practice at 4 00
a.m and that was your idea to do it but
and then you know all these nike people
are like no
no no no let's not let's not do that and
then you're like let's do it at 4am so
you got security you got brand marketing
sports marketing going no no no no no
let's not do it you're like let's do it
because that's your sustenance right i
mean to me it just makes complete sense
not to us but i don't like okay so
see we all right what you usually i'm
sleeping at 4am
you're working out so talk about that
okay
so if if your job is to try to be the
best basketball player you can be
right to do that you have to practice
you have to train right
you want to train as much as you can as
often as you can
so if you get up at 10 in the morning
train at 11
right 12 say 12 train at 12 train for
two hours 12 to two
um you have to let your body recover so
you eat recover whatever you get back
out you train start training again at
six train from six to eight
right and now you go home you shower you
eat dinner you go to bed you wake up you
do it again right those are two sessions
right now imagine you wake up at three
you train at four go four to six
come home breakfast relax
now you're back at it again nine to
eleven
right you relax and now all of a sudden
you're back at it again two to four
and now you're back at it again you know
seven to nine
look how much more training i have done
by simply starting at four
right and so now you do that and as the
years go on
the separation that you have with your
competitors and your peers just grows
larger and larger and larger and larger
and larger
and by year five or six doesn't matter
what kind of work they do in the summer
they're never going to catch up
because you're five years behind right
so it makes sense to get up and start
your day early because you can get more
work in
is that genetic or is that something you
you ingrained and trained yourself no it
really taught you that for me it was
it was just common sense like i can i
can if i start earlier i can train more
hours
and i know the other guys aren't doing
it because i know what their training
schedule is
right so i know if i do this
consistently over time
it's the gap's just going to widen and
why and why and why
and they won't be able to get that back
so it to me it was just common sense i'm
like thinking how can i get an advantage
oh
start earlier yeah let's do that how do
you develop that or where do you
where do you learn that from well i
think it's just
you know it's just a matter of what's
important to you
and what's important to you for whatever
reason
you know i i felt like i didn't feel
good about myself if i wasn't
doing everything i could to be the best
version of myself
if i felt like i left anything on the
table um
it would eat away at me i wouldn't be
able to look myself in the mirror
right so the reason why i can retire now
and be completely comfortable about it
because i know that i've done
everything i could to be the best
basketball player i could be
um and so that's where it comes from for
me you can't leave any stone unturned
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that
it's time for the best life 30 questions
of the day it's not enough to just
watch a video like this you have to do
something and take action in your life
so pull out your worksheets and answer
these questions and if you don't have
the worksheets yet you can get them for
free by signing up for the series in the
description below
here we go question number one how much
do you want to fit exercise into your
weekly schedule number two
what are the important reasons why this
must happen
right now and number three what will
keep you consistent
so you follow through and if you're
doing the best life 30 challenge with me
give me a hashtag
bestlife30 down in the comments as well
so i can celebrate you
working out even if it's for 15 minutes
20 minutes in the morning something
quick doesn't have to be a two hour
marathon workout
it gets your body moving just like music
gets you moving a little bit
so does working out and if you're you're
pumping weights
or if you are you know doing some cardio
whatever it is
moving your body getting energy getting
activity
getting motion gives you momentum
to go out and do something great i get a
lot of great ideas when i'm working out
i get a lot of great ideas in the shower
after i'm working out
and after i've finished the workout i
feel refreshed
energized ready to go and tackle my day
and
way more energy than i get if i don't if
i miss a workout
because i've got a really early morning
you know conference call or
you know i'm off speaking at some event
then i feel
sluggish it's harder to get started so
get some workout time scheduled in there
again
like 15 minutes in the morning just to
get your body moving
if you want to join the best life 30
challenge and get the free worksheets
click the link right here below me or if
you want more videos on how to optimize
your exercise check out the playlist
right there next to me
continue to believe and i'll see you
there